وانهت المحكمه العليا الاسرائيليه جلسه
للنظر في التماس ضد تعيين اتمار من كثير
وزيرا في الحكومه في انتظار اعلان قرارها
في وقت لاحق وكان من كثير قد مثل نفسه
امام المحكمه بعد ان رفض ان تقوم المستشار
القضائيه للحكومه بالدفاع عنه ويحتج مقدم
الالتماس على تعيين من كثير في هذا المنصب
الحساس بسبب ماضيه الجنائي وتاييده لباروخ
جولدشتاين منفذي مجزره المسجد الابراهيمي
في الخليل عام 1994 كما جرت الاشاره في
الالتماس الى تصريحات سابقه لرئيس الوزراء
قال فيها ان ابن كثير لن يشغل منصبه وزيرا
في حكومته
وقال ابن كثير في معرض الدفاعه عن نفسه
امام محكمه العليا الاسرائيليه التي تنظر
في التماس ضد تعيينه وزيره في الحكومه انه
لم يعد ذلك الفتى او الشاب الذي ارتكب
اخطاء في الماضي واضف بن كثير انه اليوم
لا يؤيده طرد العرب
هم يريدون ان يعيدوني الى بنغفير قبل
عشرين عاما لا تخطئوا بنغفير الفتى ابن
الرابعه عشره كان حريصا على اسرائيل اخطات
قلت ذلك من قبل وانا اقول ذلك منذ سنوات
لقد اخطات ما كان علي ان اقول انه لا يوجد
عرب او يجب طرد العدو العربي لان ذلك فهم
وكانني اقصد كل العرب ارتكبت اخطاء لكن
مرت سنوات كثيره انا اليوم في مكان اخر
وانا اكرر واقول انني لا اؤيد طرد العرب
وانا لست خليفه الحاخام كهانه